dans le 20 minutes media on revient sur
le divorce du jour le mariage TF1 M6
n'aura pas lieu que s'est-il passé
depuis un an et demi TF1 M6 font part de
leur volonté de fusionner mais cette
fusion inquiète depuis de longs mois
l'Autorité de la concurrence l'opération
n'était pas possible puisque elle aurait
créé un acteur qui aurait été ultra
dominant alors
[Musique]
pour résumer l'histoire c'était ok vous
vous mariez mais vous cédez TF1 ou vous
cédez M6 mais cette condition a fait
grincer des dents des deux côtés
vendredi dernier TF1 et M6 ont donc
décidé d'abandonner leur projet de
fusion la cession de la chaîne TF1 M6
serait de nature à permettre
l'autorisation de l'opération les
parties ont donc conclu que le projet ne
présentait plus aucune logique
industrielle alors concrètement pourquoi
tout a capoter on en parle tout de suite
sur TPMP
on en parle tout de suite je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi tout a capoter c'est
que ça faisait 75% du marché
publicitaire entre TF1 et M6 c'était pas
viable forcément voilà pour les autres
groupes et à part le nôtre parce que
nous on était les seuls groupes Canal+
vraiment parce que bon on est on a une
chaîne qui est à côté qui est une chaîne
de cryptée donc voilà qui est une chaîne
d'abonnement voilà mais c'est vrai que
pour les autres groupes c'était plutôt
compliqué et même si la patronne de
France Télévisions était pour Delphine
arnote mais Delphine bon c'est pas son
argent donc forcément
elle a pas tort quand c'est pas ton ta
boîte tu es content sur tes comptes de
tout voilà c'est pas voilà c'est normal
voilà je l'aime beaucoup mais bon c'est
normal Delphine c'est pas son argent
donc c'est l'argent de l'État donc il a
dit bah si les autres peuvent fusionner
qui fusionnent moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
ça va pas me toucher
à la fin du mois le groupe énergie
forcément c'était plutôt compliqué donc
à mon avis ils étaient pas chaud si je
les ai pas eu voilà et donc ça faisait
trop TF1 et M6 ensemble sachez qu'ils
ont dépensé 100 millions de frais
d'avocats pour cette fusion c'est
incroyable donc voilà et donc ça ne se
fait pas terminé donc
c'est vrai que ça aurait été compliqué
alors il y a oui qui pourrait acheter
qui peut racheter
donc
il y a il y a le Xavier Niel qui est
cité également voilà de Free j'embrasse
d'ailleurs Xavier des amis avec des amis
voilà et puis il y a d'autres gens qui
font des étrangers
je pense pas je pense que chacun des
groupes voilà il va avoir il va avoir je
vous dis va avoir cinq offres voilà et
donc après M6
canal je sais pas après après c'est vrai
que voilà est-ce que c'est intéressant
il faudra voir parce qu'il y a un nombre
de chaînes voilà qui qu'on peut pas
dépasser donc faut voir mais voilà en
tout cas il y aura 5 sur Non non non non
je sais pas cinq acteurs en tout cas il
y a cinq acteurs qui vont faire une
proposition je crois 5 ou 6 je sais pas
qui mais en tout cas on vous tiendra au
courant voilà en tout cas c'était juste
que la fusion TF1 M6 donc on a
énormément parlé
ne se fait pas